you dare enter this house on a Friday
afternoon what are you thinking
math slavery a beautiful sunny
California to Friday afternoon I got
this [ __ ] - beep smoke when they took
him to the hospital what are you gonna
do I feel bad for Tony Ferguson it was
the fight of the year but now it
simplifies to 155 and it puts Calabar
Tony Ferguson up against Conor McGregor
so that's the best thing you got about
this now we see what's gonna happen
there now they gotta force his hand
beside that it's Friday I don't give a
[ __ ] about MMA I don't give a [ __ ] about
GMA I don't give a [ __ ] about the
Grammys or the Oscars it's all about you
or me [ __ ] and this collar be
briefing right here what's wrong when he
that the captain and we got the
perennial always from perennial little
Sun the sun's out the birds are chirping
I did all my golf this week now you just
sit back and relax with the family I
ain't getting on stage like tonight's
date night with my wife's come on I was
gonna watch the fights but now I got a
little responsibility but until then
we've got refit without a book I got my
daughter I got my wife I got a notebook
I'm ready a rocky understand and went to
jiu-jitsu today nice three days this
week I hit my goals why because I wrote
it down one day I'm gonna do 322 this
week when I started you JIT to three
years ago I should only go once a week
would take me a week to [ __ ] recover
you believe that now
times a week thanks for you guys for
keeping me in check and I'm saying and
you're also keeping me in check with the
pipe of debts la PIPA del I'm worth day
you understand me uncle Joey looking
good feeling good emotionally mentally
spiritually getting ready for [ __ ]
Baltimore my boobies on the sixteenth
and then from there we clatter we take
the body 11 [ __ ] live in Nyack
New York I'm just resting up for you
people you understand me if I go out a
lot
then I burn out that I'm not the best
that I can be you follow me
but Joey what's with the [ __ ] what's
with the [ __ ] a beating
nice kick back his little breeze listen
I'm sure you're happy with yet but
listen California as California
[ __ ] good googly moogly it's 80
degrees relax
nobody's [ __ ] bothered me I did two
podcast resets three Jujitsu one [ __ ]
staff a [ __ ] strength and conditioning
thing I do you know I wrote I wrote two
two paragraphs every day in my book my
[ __ ] mission for the week is
completed had the most important thing I
got the smoked [ __ ] reefer with my
favorite [ __ ] people don't
forget Borgata Atlantic City July 29th
dropping bombs on your mom's taking it
back to my [ __ ] old stomping grounds
respect let's try this [ __ ] cat food
here this is from Gino my man man always
giving me cutting edge [ __ ]
marijuana over they had a [ __ ] speed
we do you understand me but this is it
this is as good as it gets people you
know uncle Joey relax
I'm the relaxation mode I bother nobody
I got the sun shining on my face little
vitamin B and that's it and that's that
we're doing a podcast Sunday night six
o'clock we come at you this week you
understand me that's how we roll why
because that's how we do things we
wanted to a little something on the
Lord's Day Monday I got a surprise for
you [ __ ] and besides that that's
it that's that
why talk when you could smoke I'm saying
Oh livin like a [ __ ] doctor I'm happy
that you [ __ ] a happy dude what
are you kind of suckers this week one of
them possible you follow me
you guys support the podcast you know I
got your [ __ ] back from Timmy
Holloway junior that would be spooky
tough [ __ ] talking lad the [ __ ]
Bobby and crystals to my other crystal
out of [ __ ] you time you know I got
you [ __ ] Leon there's so many
[ __ ] with family waterboxx a
Brandi Lynn Tommy Easter coming on in a
couple minutes for the 4/20 report give
him some love and I said people you guys
are the champions of my life and I told
you on a Friday [ __ ] afternoon that's
as good as it gets cuz I'm PO tantos
nobody understand me but I love you
[ __ ] I thought I'm less dead
weight
don't forget if you go out tonight keep
your eyes open
Isis is everywhere